[Music]
hi and welcome to i'd like to know this
is our question and answer program where
we get the privilege of answering
questions that you send in from the word
of god i'm ca murray associate speaker
here at secrets unsealed and i'm in the
company of pastor daniel miranda
associate speaker here at secrets
unsealed pastor boy is away on
assignment uh as we speak doing the work
of the lord so we have been left to man
the battlements as it were
and it is our privilege and our pleasure
to do so again as always we make you
this pledge
that when you send in a question
if an answer can be found in the word of
god we will find it in the word of god
and bring it to you from the word of god
we feel that it is too late in earth's
history
to be spending time
dealing with
the thoughts of men we want to hear a
word from the lord amen so we promise to
give you a word from the lord if a word
from the lord can indeed be found we
will give it to you and uh try to do it
that way
should you like to participate by
sending in a question you can write to
tv
at some tv
dot org that is tv at some tv
s-u-m-t-v
dot o-r-g and we will try to get
to your questions as quickly as possible
we have a fairly impressive list of
questions so if you don't hear an answer
right away
we promise we're coming to it we will
get to it as soon as we can
pastor miranda being bilingual is
answering questions that come in from
spanish viewers uh to our spanish
channel so his duties are divided and of
course pastor bohr and i have duties
also but we will get to them we promise
to do so and try to give them uh due
difference as we work our way through
through your questions pastor if you
would uh open up in prayer then we're
going to go to a question that i think
is going to take the balance of this
particular program
so let's open up in prayer sure i can
let's pray
dear heavenly father as pastor c i said
we do not
dare to speak our own thoughts but only
your words
and as we
try to answer these questions dear lord
we pray for the
enlightenment of your holy spirit
help us lord to say the right words the
words that your people need to hear in
the name of jesus we pray amen amen amen
a question came in and
[Music]
i wanted to spend a little time on it it
comes from andrea
and there are so many ways that this
question can be dealt with so we're
going to try to broad sweep uh our our
answer pastor because um
uh
she wants to know how do i get involved
in ministry
now i don't know if she's talking
about being involved as a woman in
ministry or she's talking about being
involved in ministry in general so i'm
going to try to cover as much of this as
i can
you know to kind of get a feel for for
what she's asking and what she needs
vis-a-vis answer
but i know we've talked about give me
your definition pastor or a working
definition for you for what is ministry
oh thank you well ministry is a broad
concept in the scriptures yes indeed
it's uh we can spend two or three or
more programs speaking just a ministry
here
but a very practical and and summarized
definition of ministry that i found is
um
ministry is the spiritual work or
service of any christian
or a group of christians especially
evangelism or a ministry
directed towards the needs of the people
now in the bible i find a very good
example of ministry and i think we can
use this this definition also
hebrews chapter 1
verse 14
we read here about the work of the
angels
the bible says here that i'm reading
from the king james version
the bible says speaking about the angels
are they not all
ministering spirits yes sent forth to
minister for them
who shall be heirs
of salvation
so we see here that
ministry has to do with salvation
ministry has to do with working for
those
whom god wants to save
that would be a
something we can start building on when
we talk about ministry
um i agree any attempt any desire will
more than desire any doing of meeting
the spiritual needs
and and to a lesser extent the physical
needs
of mankind is ministry that's right so
when the question is asked
how do i get into ministry
there are so many ways to answer that
because there are so many ways that we
can minister one to another there's
pulpit ministry there's preaching
ministry there's pastoral ministry
there's helping ministry literature as
literature ministry
and all of these are very necessary part
of doing the work of god all kinds of
ministries
one of the things i think we we need to
affirm
is that
all ministry does not take place on
sabbath morning in the past right that's
just the beginning of ministry that's
just one type of ministry in fact uh
daniel i dare say
that more ministry takes place outside
of the pulpit absolutely then does in
the pulpit that's where real ministry
takes place yeah that's a real ministry
takes place i'll i'll tell you something
one years ago i had i was working with a
local radio station in new york city
and i had a roller skating ministry oh
they
had rented a roller skating rink
on monday nights
and i was working with this radio
station i had a talk show and they said
we need someone
so that we're not just roller skating
the christian music we need someone to
at nine o'clock do a little certain
30-minute teaching
and we don't have anybody and so i said
i'll do it
i was i was teaching roller skating
because i'm i i say this humbly i'm i'm
a very good roller skater yeah in fact
i'll say i was a very good roller skater
in fact i did a presentation at a
general conference on roller skates
and i did it at 3abn a couple times also
but
i led more people to the lord in that
roller skating rink wow than i did
in my pulpit
so ministry takes place anywhere you
find it anywhere someone is in need and
you can answer that need in christ when
you're doing you're doing ministry did
you have another text you're looking at
no i'm just thinking of
um
about the question that the sister was
asking how do i get involved in ministry
i think of two stories in the bible one
is the samaritan woman when she had that
encounter with jesus yes and when
when jesus introduces himself to her as
the messiah yes
and all her brokenness and all her past
was forgiven and was healed right in
that encounter and we see her
right away going to the city and and
telling people about jesus and
and ellen white comments on that story
in this hour of ages and she says that
everyone who is born into the kingdom of
god is born as a missionary yes so
um
it is it is impossible
to love jesus
and not do ministry because ministry is
the response
of our love to jesus of a newborn
experience the other the other example i
find in the bible is the god the
godharians the
the two demoniacs and gaddara
when
again jesus heals them
and then jesus sends them to proclaim
the good news to their friends and
relatives and the capitalists yes yes
yes
you will find
that
some of christ's
i use the term best ministry
was done in one-on-one situations some
of his most powerful statements uh
marvel not that you must be born again
one-on-one uh one thing thou lacketh one
on one
take up your cross and follow me one on
one
the statement
uh
we're going to have
the lord's looking for are people who
are going to worship him in spirit and
truth one-on-one at the samaritan well
um so ministry
uh again it buttresses the point it's
not always done in in large crowds or
large groups or on sabbath morning but
ministry can take place one-on-one in
fact some of the most effective ministry
is done
one-on-one
and i think as we come down closer to
the end of time we were talking about
this before um
doing public evangelism is becoming
expensive when i first started doing
meetings and uh
we would do six-week meetings in
seven-week meetings you know not these
little short ones we'd start preaching
right after labor day or rather right
after fourth of july and preach straight
through to a labor day you know
six days a week sometimes seven days a
week
and we'd get good baptisms but when i
first started doing those we could do
those for about
thirty five hundred four thousand
dollars
now
uh tens of thousands of dollars to do
that kind of thing
so your yield per dollar is going down
because it costs so much more to bring
in an evangelist or to do a meeting
yourself internet does help
but uh internet and television
they send your signal around the world
but they may not necessarily contact a
local community the community where the
church sits and ellen white tells us
that
we ought not neglect the local community
where the church sits and she also says
and i'm sure you you know this quote
that if we were kind tenderhearted
pitiful there would be 100 accessions to
the truth well there's now there's only
one
so that be speaks a personal ministry as
opposed to not as opposed to but in
addition to a public ministry so that
evangelism is more a lifestyle than an
event
an event is a big meeting we hold a big
event then we go back away i i in my uh
syllabus i call that gorilla evangelism
you know it's like guerrilla warfare you
know you come out you shoot off a few
bullets and you disappear in the jungle
and you come out and you shoot off a few
bullets then you disappear into the
jungle that's guerrilla warfare well we
we had guerrilla evangelism you you set
up a meeting uh in in the east we have
tent meetings or you rent a hall and you
appear
fire off a few bullets and then you
go back and disappear and then a couple
years later you do another one you know
gorilla and the lord has blessed us but
more effective ministry it it works a
little slower but
ministry one-on-one small groups
families we found to be just as
expensive as effective and much less
expensive than than than big meetings uh
in countries
you are from colombia uh i've spent a
lot of time in latin countries
churches are smaller groups are smaller
and they are more effective than these
large megachurches spending a lot of
money on meetings which sometimes have
good yields you know you bring in a mark
finley you're bringing a dog bachelor
you're bringing a stephen boar you're
bringing people like this and you get
yield but you spend a lot of money doing
it
and if that yield is not followed up by
personal evangelism
you still don't keep them you know it
takes more than three weeks to make a
sinner a saint it takes more than three
weeks to make an adventist out of
somebody you can get them started but if
you're going to keep them going you got
to put in a little bit more more time
ellen white says this
she says we need workers who can put new
life into old methods of labor and can
invent new plans of awakening the
interests of the church members and
reaching men and women of the world
that's why one of the things that that
led me to work with this radio station
to do roller skating ministry roller
skating ministry yes yes we brought
people into the adventist church from
the roller skates to the baptismal proof
you know it's a new method and there are
some saying well you can't do that well
yeah you can because it's a new day
means will be devised she says to reach
hearts
some of the methods used in this work
will be different from methods used in
the past but let no one because of this
block the wheels by criticism so if
somebody comes up with a new idea
see if it has any merit
and if it has merit use it because uh
you know god can use some new methods
i'll tell you about something else that
we did in new york and just a little bit
there are some minds she says which do
not grow with the work but allow the
work to grow far beyond them those who
do not discern and adapt themselves to
the increasing demands of the work
should not stand blocking the wheels and
thus hindering the advancement of others
so for someone comes up if god gives
somebody a new methodology
see if it works try it out and see if it
works for the lord
when i was pastoring
and then went into the conference office
in communications
um i did a little
test with a number of churches and um i
want to run through it
with you and you you'll be in my
congregation sure okay okay
um i asked the question how many live
within five blocks of the church that
they attend
that's about
half a mile
you will find and i found that less than
five percent live in the area of the
church we commute to church like we
commute to work most people don't live
in that area
that poses some problems
because we are not members of that
community we come in on sabbath
worship for several hours and then we
disappear you know and the community
doesn't see us again until the next
sabbath
all right here's my question
what right do we you and i
as as members of that church what right
do we have to come into that community
what moral right
well uh not much right precisely we
don't have any no you know we bought the
land we built a building or we somebody
else lesson we bought the building but
that doesn't give us a moral right to be
there we're just we're just there you
know we have a legal right because we
paid for the building but what's the
moral justification of being there
why then daniel
would the church be located there
why is it there
well because we bought it that's why
it's there
okay so it was affordable by the time it
was purchased precisely
we had the money we bought it so that
gives us again the legal justification
for our presence there
but here's the next question
how does that community
benefit
because a group of adventists are there
much yeah yeah um that question is left
for us to answer
if we come in
on
saturday
use all the parking spaces
uh churches here in california have big
beautiful parking lots back east we
don't we don't have those there's too
many it's just too crowded yeah so we're
parking in front of your park on the
streets well you know what you see
in front of other people's homes
we park
uh go in the church close the door
praise the lord
sing oh i love jesus
and then we go home
so the question is how is the community
benefited by the fact that a bunch of
juventus are there
they're not benefited at all in fact
usually they're inconvenienced
because we're parking on the streets and
you know we're just our presence is
there but we're not making any impact on
the community because we don't we don't
live there
so then if we are not
a blessing to the community
what moral right do we have to stay
there
we're just we're like
walmart kmart
you know
we're just we're just in the community
but we're not a blessing to the
community many times
uh the community members don't even know
we're there
i did i did a a survey when i was when i
was in the communications director i was
working uh
with our conference i went to
uh
a house picked at random on the street
where the church sat
and i asked whoever would answer the
door adult i asked them five questions
talking about the adventist church i
asked them what kind of church is that
most of the people
didn't know
and many of them
told me that church has been there that
adventist church has been here 5 10 15
years or longer but they still didn't
know
what kind of church that was they knew
that they worship on saturday because
that's the day we all show up
but they didn't have
uh any other real way to to get a hold
on what that church is all about
then i asked them what do they believe
most of the people didn't know they knew
something about saturday because that's
the day they see us
but they didn't know much else
i asked have you ever been inside
i think
if i remember i'm looking at my notes
about 10 percent had okay 90 had not
never been invited to anything never
been inside don't know what kind of
worship they have so i asked them what
is their worship like
well we don't know because we've never
been there
there was one
church that is uh adventist church that
has pretty energetic worship and it
spills out into so
they knew about that one because of the
music and they could hear you know that
kind of thing was pastored by a friend
of mine by the way but it was very
very energetic so they knew about that
one but for the most part they didn't
know and then i asked them this question
daniel
i asked are they nice people
here's the answer that i got
i wrote it down
i don't know
okay i guess
they mind their business
i mind mine
that's pretty sad for a group of
adventists it is they mind their
business on my mind which says
i don't have any contact with them
and they don't have any contact with me
yeah
but isn't our job from what you said
isn't our job to make contact with him
in the name of jesus definitely and it's
very sad that um
i think many people out there have that
conception of us that we are in our
business yes and well since they're in
their business we're in our business too
yes and they don't they know little
about us
um
we are not as involved maybe we have
developed a kind of concept of religion
and ministry morally surgical
that christianity has to do with the
sabbath i remember i heard someone
that was making an illustration in a
sermon that some of us might be just
seven eleven christians
we keep the seventh day and at eleven
yeah a.m or by service that's and just
that yeah and uh and we may be
going to church and and worshipping the
lord but we're not involved in our
community even if we don't live there i
i believe that even if the members
didn't live there at least they would do
something for the community uh and get
mingled with them and minister to their
needs yeah that would
at least make some yeah impact but even
living that would be even better i'm
sure you are familiar with that famous
statement from um
uh
one page 147 of ministry of healing yeah
christ mingled with the people yeah
she says will bring success in mind with
people he mingled with them methane then
made them follow me we tend to lead with
follow me yes uh and and forget about
the mingling uh and meeting their needs
but those are very very necessary amen
if you're going to get people to follow
and i think that quote um
summarizes and answers the questions
very the question very well how do i get
involved in ministry well i have the
example of jesus how he did it
christ method alone she says will give
true success yes yes
um
all right let me a couple more points
all right
let's pretend that um
a neighborhood board
wants to build a
walmart in the community now you've been
in walmart yes you know what a
successful store walmart is
i don't have to preach to you how
valuable
having a walmart is to a community jobs
uh the prices are low uh
they're not as low as they once were but
they're still pretty low
so having a walmart is a value to a
community
um
so they're looking for a place to put
the walmart
now daniel we can't
we can't tear down houses to put up a
walmart
that defeats the purpose so we've got to
find a place to put this walmart
that meets the following criteria okay
one
it's got to be a place that
people from the community don't really
go to too much
so that if we tear it down
there won't be any community outcry
because people are in the community
aren't really involved in it you follow
me yeah yeah if it's there good if it's
not going they won't mind us
yeah they were mine okay
um
two
it's got to be a place
that um
the community will not see it as being a
real benefit
it's a place that is not open too much
you know it's not available to the
community
maybe once a week or so but not open too
much
it's a place that doesn't provide any
particular services for the community
now what place
let's put our heads together we're
intelligent people we went to school
let's put our heads together what place
would would meet that criteria the
church yeah the church building yeah the
church building yeah sadly um
so we don't want to be unfair
we call the church board together
and
we asked the church board
give us
ten reasons not a hundred not a thousand
not fifty not twenty five just ten
ten reasons why the church
is better for the community
than walmart
10 reasons why the church should stay
and the walmart should go
do you think most church boards would
find that an easy task or difficult
difficulty yeah extremely difficult
extremely difficult
um
we probably could hatch up some
theological premise but i'm talking
about ten concrete reasons
um
and then here's the the last question
as far as meeting the needs of the
community
if the church packed up and moved away
would anybody notice
would anybody care
very little
yeah
i think life would go on pretty much
as usual
and there would be certainly no outcry
and maybe very
few tears shed
now what does that say about
adventism as we practice it today
we're failing to fulfill
christ's commission
of uh meeting people's needs and
preaching the gospel yeah as we should
yeah they're and we're not being good
witness precisely
it's more than just showing up on
sabbath in fact ellen white says and
these are my words not hers but i'll
paraphrase if all we do is come and sing
oh i love jesus and preach and pray we
are doing our god and ourselves and our
church
a terrible disservice
because it's it's more than that it's
it's it's meeting needs here's the truth
daniel about about religion
people don't join the church anymore
because you say
we're the remnant
first of all they don't know what that
means that's advent speak
or
even because you say we have the truth
they join the church for a couple of
reasons
one
because the truth that you preach
answers the questions that they have
it makes sense to them
and
the way you administer truth
says you care about me
people today
for better for worse are very relational
just saying we've got the truth and they
don't is not enough
i want to see how your truth affects
how you treat me
what you have to say to me
even in this this quarter's sabbath
school lesson
and we studied it together
christ is very concerned god is very
concerned heaven is very concerned
as to how
you treat your fellow man
that's going to be weighed in your
acceptance or rejectance rejection when
it comes down to the end of the gospel
there's a lot more we could say i'm
looking at the clock on the wall which
has become our enemy
[Laughter]
but you you get my point now if this
person was talking about a pulpit
ministry that's a whole another program
but ministry is where you find it again
god bless you keep sending your
questions we'll do the best to answer
them we'll see you again next time
bye-bye
[Music]
you